quickly and easily as for a of Woodhouse
what client maintains and cross the
rivers to cause their ballots in pursuit
of an idea to participate in the process
of determining the political will of the
people
a story of election officials who know
their dedication and passion for our
electoral democracy and country worked
night and day to ensure a free and fair
election and the rapid collation of
results it is a story of an eighth
senate democratic nation continue to
move forward and defying odds this is a
story borne out by observer missions
from South Africa and around the world
which unanimously endorsed dis elections
as free and fair it is a story borne out
by the human research Sciences Council
on foot experience survey which found
the following which one the following
which made the following findings Ravin
97% of sampled voters found the voting
procedures inside the voting station
easy to understand 96% of sampled voters
feel that the election procedures were
free and fair 96 percent of voters voice
general satisfaction with the quality of
services rendered by the IC officials to
voters to represent expressing a neutral
position and 1% dissatisfied 68 percent
of voters took less than 15 minutes to
reach their voting stations and on
average 16 minutes in the queue before
voting 88 percent of voters found what
in the accessible to persons with
disabilities and the elderly were 6% did
not it is a story borne out by analysts
observers and commentators who have not
we have not seen isolated problems but
widespread celebration and affirmation
of electoral democracy in action in the
in our country ladies and gentlemen each
election presents us all with yet
Estella thirst for electoral democracy
tonight we can proud to portraying as a
nation that our democracy has once again
withstood this examination and continues
to endure with strength and fortitude
this is a tribute to the founding
mothers and fathers of our democracy who
put in place a constitution grounded in
democracy and the rule of law it is a
tribute to the founding mothers and
fathers of the electron Commission who
put in place an electoral process which
is transparent inclusive credible and
highly resilient it is a tribute to
political parties and their leaders and
contestants who have respected the
Constitution the election laws and
regulations to fight hard but fair and
ultimately it is a tribute to the people
of South Africa who have tasted
democracy chance benefit 25 years ago
continue to display an unquenchable fire
for democracy justice and freedom for
all after all the people have
their political will which will soon be
declared by the chairperson to every
person who participated supported went
assisted and voted in these elections we
say Excel
thank you in personal level I don t
forget to thank you thank you very much
CEO thank you very much
these are the reflections of a man who
has not known much sleep for months on
end to his latest availing key and his
team continued to support him I thank
you very much
it gives me great pleasure to invite the
chairperson of the Electoral Commission
to discharge a constitutional duty that
the Commission has I invite him to come
here and announce the results of these
elections of 2019 sheperson thank you
program director it is indeed a great
honor to stand before you today
your excellency President of the
Republic of South Africa the Honourable
Cyril Ramaphosa His Excellency
the former president of United Republic
of Tanzania mistake equator the Speaker
of Parliament miss better and Deputy
Speaker Sonali fellow commissioners has
already acknowledged by the previous
speaker ministers and deputy ministers
present year honourable leaders and
representatives of the political parties
chairpersons and numbers of fellow
chapter nine institutions presence
members of the judiciary present High
Commissioners Masada's members of the
diplomatic corps
Suhani come over our chief electoral
officer mr. ma ma Buddha and fellow
members of his ex Co provincial
electoral officers able to an alumn
bocce
members of the domestic and
international observer missions that
have graced this auspicious occasion
traditional leaders international
members of civil society members of the
NGOs representatives of the faith-based
organizations present here
members of the organized labor as well
as the business community who have
joined us here members of the Fourth
Estate our media
distinguished guests ladies and
gentlemen on behalf of the team the
mighty team that is here in front of you
that constitutes the Electoral
Commission it is indeed an honor to
welcome you all for the announcement of
the results of the 2019 national and
provincial elections the constitution of
our country in its founding provisions
permits us as the nation to approach
universal adult suffrage national common
voters roll regular elections and
multi-party system of democratic
government and yes we had our share of
multi-party contesting this round
it then establishes the electoral
commission and mandates it to carry out
very simple tasks to manage the
elections ensure the elections are free
and fair and to declare the results just
to paraphrase those the mandate but as
the fellow CEO has indicated that
particular task requires a more
distinguished and accomplished young men
and women as this country's young men
and women have short years the
Commission we are proud once again to
meet this mandate and by declaring the
national and provincial elections 2019
to be free and fair and to announce the
results of those elections within the
three days that we finished Poli
we can do this because of the legal
framework including the Constitution and
the electoral legislation along with the
systems the processes under which
elections are conducted and provides an
electoral architecture based on
transparency and inclusivity to ensure
credible and elections with integrity we
can do this because of the 200,000 or so
federal South Africans who volunteered
and with staff members of the Commission
who made sure that they will not the
democracy dwindle on their watch
we can do this because the political
parties who are key stakeholders and
very colorful and effervescent
contestants to this elections they share
one thing and that thing in common is a
vision for a peaceful prosperous and a
democratic country under the
Constitution and the rule of law excuse
me
we can do this because the people of
South Africa continue also to believe in
our democracy they support the freedom
of choice and the Justice Dave's and
gentlemen 14 days ago South Africa
celebrated the anniversary of our first
democratic free and fair elections 25
years on we can proudly say as a nation
that we remain firmly rooted in the
democratic ideals that we adopted in
1994 and our country remains a shining
beacon of democracy and human rights for
all it is now my honor and privilege to
then do the easier part than our CEO had
to do it is to announce the results and
we will start with the in the province
of the Eastern Cape the following
parties will be represented in the
provincial legislature for the next five
years
the African transformation movement with
one seat
the Fayetteville plus with one seat the
United Democratic Movement with two
seats the economic freedom fighters with
five seats the Official Opposition in
the province is the Democratic Alliance
with ten seats and finally the majority
party in the Eastern Cape is the African
National Congress with 44 seats
[Applause]
in the province of the Free State the
following parties will be represented in
the provincial legislature for the next
five years the fray plus with one seat
the economic freedom fighters with four
seats the Official Opposition in the
province is the Democratic Alliance with
six seats and the majority party in the
first stage is the African National
Congress with 19 seats in the province
of halting the following parties will be
represented in the provincial
legislature for the next five years the
African Christian Democratic Party with
one seat in Qatar Freedom Party with one
seat the freight front plus with three
seats the economic freedom fighters with
elevenses the Official Opposition in the
province is the Democratic Alliance with
twenty seats and the majority party in
housing is the African National Congress
with 37 seats
[Applause]
in the province of Wasilla natal the
funding parties would be represented in
the provincial legislature for the next
five years the African transformation
movement with one seat the African
Christian Democratic Party with one seat
the minority front with one seat the
economic freedom fighters with AIDS its
Democratic Alliance with eleven seats
and the Official Opposition in the
province is in cata freedom party with
13 seats and the majority party in the
Zulu natal heaven announce there it is
the African National Congress with 44
seats and the projects of Limpopo the
following parties will be represented in
the provincial legislature for the next
five years the faith Fant plus with one
seat the democratic alliance with three
seats the Official Opposition in the
province is the economic freedom
fighters with seven seats and the
majority party in Burpo is the African
National Congress with 38
the potential in the province of neuquén
mallanna the following parties will be
represented in the provincial
legislature for the next five years the
fray plus with one the Democratic
Alliance three seeds and the Official
Opposition is the economic freedom
fighters with four seats and the
majority party in a pom Alana is the
African National Congress with twenty to
six in the province of the Northwest the
following parties will be represented in
the provincial legislature for the next
five years
Mayfair plus with two suits the